[Music]
if the deep ocean is the last great
frontier it's the last major piece of
our planet we still don't know about
this is a really under explored part of
the world and yet it makes up almost the
biggest volume of the living space on
planet Earth
we have 8 million tons of plastic that
are leaving land going into the ocean
every year some of our members are going
to die if we don't do the right thing
now there is a special place on this
precious planet where man has never been
unreached unexplored unknown that is
about to change
[Music]
[Applause]
the earth is mainly ocean the sea covers
more than 70% of the planet's surface
but we know little about much of it
little about the life it supports the
underwater Kingdom is largely a mystery
more than three-quarters of it has never
been mapped or surveyed and this place
holds a special interest for scientists
it's why in a programming first we're
taking you 300 meters below into the
least known and least protected waters
to the Aldabra atoll part of the
Seychelles in the Indian Ocean for three
live one-hour broadcast on or close to
the surface it is a wondrous paradise of
diversity where creatures survive and
thrive
[Music]
but deeper still we can only wonder what
life-forms exist some we will know and
some we certainly work
this is a really under explored part of
the world in fact not just the Indian
Ocean as a place but the zone of the
water that this expedition is going to
be exploring is one of the least known
parts of the world ocean and yet it
makes up almost the biggest volume of
the living space on planet Earth so here
we have this layer of water which is
just below the sunlit Zone it's in the
in this Twilight world where animals are
shadows or they're seen only by the
flashlights on their bodies that are
bioluminescent
we just don't know what's going to be
there and we can be certain that we're
going to find dozens if not hundreds of
new species man may never have been here
but his impact is felt nevertheless and
the signs are not good species that need
our protection instead become entangled
in the deadly detritus deposited by
humans who all too often give not a
thought to the consequence the lagoons
here offer breeding ground
and nesting for this precious species
life is fragile enough without the harm
done by humans it is a constant battle
to survive it is Nature's Way but the
real danger is unquestionably man-made
here plastic is the enemy we have 8
million tons of plastics that are
leaving land going into the ocean every
year and as a result we've now got over
five trillion piece of plastic floating
on the surface and most of them are this
big they are micro plastics
and rather than it being these islands
out there really it is a fine soup of
these pieces that are basically
impossible to pick up we can only
account for a tiny fraction of that 8
million tons going into the ocean
actually on the surface so the big
question is where is the rest of that
plastic going and we expect it's sinking
the previous mission to Bermuda showed
how the problem of plastic percolates
down human debris polluting the food
chain below but it also revealed an
undiscovered web of life new species
coral forests and fossilized beaches
they're expecting similar but better in
the Seychelles this is where the
scientists are based on the outskirts of
Oxford Paris Stephanie dis has just
finished analyzing samples from their
last mission in Bermuda and is now
preparing to head to the Indian Ocean
with us
so does this encourage you when it comes
to what you might find in the Seychelles
I think we're actually gonna find many
more new species and new environments
and Seychelles and the reason for that
is if you imagine Bermuda that has been
an area that has been studied for over a
hundred years and it's a relatively
species poor area compared to the
Seychelles so if you go to the
Seychelles everything below 30 metres is
virtually unknown and you'll hope in the
next two years to be looking at species
maybe in this laboratory maybe that you
didn't know existed that's probably very
very certain to happen we already know
whenever you go especially in deep water
environments that's below 200 meters the
possibility of finding new species is
it's very high so we're definitely gonna
find a lot of new microscopic species
but also the occasional kind of big
megafauna like 2 meter long corals or
sponges that will be new to science this
is a coelacanth it's about 2 meters long
and this is living fossil essentially it
has been around for 400 million years
but scientists up to 80 years ago
thought it was extinct 60 60 66 million
years ago we believe that is a very high
possibility of finding the same fish
around our Dabra and
seychelles what about the chance of
finding a new species I think there are
possibilities because no one has been
that deep in the indian ocean before so
who knows what creatures will adorn
laboratory walls when this mission is
complete but all this isn't just for the
interest of the scientists it's also
about persuading people that it's not
all doom and gloom when it comes to the
ocean and that there remains a positive
story to tell about life in the deep a
story about life-forms that flourish and
which can continue to do so with help
from us before it's too late
it's been estimated in the ocean as a
whole of those over 2 million species of
marine animals and other life out be and
so on and only 10% of those have been
described so 90% of life in the ocean
has not been described by scientists in
the Seychelles specifically I expect
there to be coral habitats in deep water
so below the depth of scuba diving where
we have what accordingly the photic
reefs and Mesa photic obviously stands
for middle life so you can picture these
as reefs which are living in the
Twilight on the on the seabed so just in
for in terms of kind of putting a large
piece of the overall jigsaw puzzle of
where life occurs in the ocean the
Indian Ocean and this expedition is
really important
the mission is in many ways a health
check of the Dean at the University of
Derby scientists are studying a
desperately whirring underwater event a
vast bleaching of coral the results of
rising sea temperatures caused by
climate change
it causes coral to turn a ghostly white
and possibly died the knock-on effect on
the oceans marine life is devastating
what happens when you switch those
conditions and unfortunately these
corals are designed in usually
nutrient-poor waters so they're they're
living on the edge of life so to speak
and it's like single change I can
actually have a quite a large knock-on
effect on coral and on the whole
ecosystem which the u.s. ocean
monitoring agency has tracked a surge of
warm water and the likely damage it does
to coral their evidence points towards
damage occurring exactly where we're
heading the Aldabra atoll in the Indian
Ocean I've seen near 100% of coral cover
in many instances all around the world
and it's a beautiful thing to behold
unfortunately that is becoming a rare
and rare event yet further afield
usually too far offshore reefs to still
see this coral contains the most diverse
ecosystems on the planet
it provides a habitat a shelter a food
source and its loss is doing untold
damage the ocean deserves better
it's Southampton not the Seychelles
but this pool is where our preparations
begin even inflating my lifejacket
prudes a challenge but we're being put
through our paces in sea survival in
case the worst occurs and abandoning
ship becomes a reality unconscious if he
stops breathing potentially giving
rescuer breaths
it looks fun and it was give a chapter
and a botting can anchor the news
without a second thought but getting
into a life raft
engage let's just say it was a challenge
taken on with more enthusiasm than
dignity it's not the easiest evolution
climbing into a life raft it's not
always a matter of strength it's
something a little bit of technique and
then I'm gonna to get your momentum to
climb into it and I mean obviously the
amount of time that you can spend in the
water in salt won't climb that's where
the word water might be up to 28 degrees
it's still open body temperature so over
a period of time you act on the cooldown
and a loose energy the air shacks and
marine mammals will certainly be a
concern for science correspondent thomas
moore and the rest of the team it was
all a sometimes nerve testing prelude to
our trip into the unknown
[Music]
yeah good after guys
we're not ready but the success of this
trip will depend on the technology the
pictures have to get from our special
submersibles to your screen and we want
to give you the best possible view of an
underwater world that's never been seen
before that's where these guys come in
although the lights look steady on these
in fact what each of on each of these
there is a array of LEDs and those LEDs
are switching on and off very fast and
that sends a binary signal so digital
signal that we can encode anything from
video voice etc on each of submarines
and send that to send that to the
surface I think is that this really is
the first time that we've actually
achieved this operationally there are a
lot of things that you take for granted
above the water on land like the GPS
like your radio like satellites none of
that works underwater so we have to work
within what we've got so on the water
we've got challenges from pressure we've
got challenges from saltwater we've got
challenges from that lack of
transmission of electromagnetic wireless
wives and so it means that commissioning
we've been working predominantly with
sound for doing communications and
positioning subsea to get the pictures
from the submarines we've got two
cameras to go through all these systems
and a vision mixer and then it's
transmitted through the water up to the
surface of the boat where we where we
can manipulate pictures and that comes
to the blue comm system through the
water and then at that point it's then
mixed in to the rest of the program or
the other cameras we have on the ship
and then from that point is transmitted
over the system on the ship got that if
not here's how we hope it will happen
the two submersibles will sit 300 metres
below the ocean the
that level sea-salt pressure and a lack
of electromagnetic waves will stifle any
traditional broadcasting a problem with
a groundbreaking solution a receiver
will be lowered between the submersibles
and our ship ocean Zephyr to act as an
antenna LED lights on each of the
submersibles will send audio and video
information to the platform which in
turn will transmit the information to
the mothership by cable where a
satellite link will send our broadcast
to your screens it is time we went
beneath the waves
[Music]
the oceans are
our way it's a joint effort with the
Seychelles and nekton who with an a-list
endorsement for the mission are clear
about what they want to achieve to
discover the secrets of the deep
before the oceans demise triggers
we've been looking up when we should
have been looking down I mean we've had
this great era of space exploration and
that has pushed back the frontiers of
our knowledge but now we stand at the
point where the most important part of
our planet the deep ocean is the least
known part of our planet and the most
important part of our planet our
floating home during filming at Aldabra
will be the offshore supply vessel ocean
Zephyr specially adapted for the trip
the real urgency around it is yeah we've
got a short window of opportunity to try
and shift the dial the scientists are
saying look we need 30% of the ocean
protected by 2030 and we need we have an
opportunity to do it now before we hit
too many more points of no return where
the demise of the ocean could mean our
demise the ocean Zephyr left Bremerhaven
in Germany on the 31st of January
traveling through the Mediterranean Sea
before going through the Suez Canal and
the Red Sea past the coasts of Yemen and
Somalia two countries engulfed in
conflict and where lawlessness and
piracy prevail and soon it will reach
the remote island of Aldabra in the
Seychelles from there submarines on
board will attempt to dive to a depth of
300 meters the equivalent of the Eiffel
Tower
the proximity to lawless Somalia
presents a problem of piracy that we
pray we don't encounter it is one reason
we will have a security team on board
with us there are concerns of piracy
we've got to work with with the crew and
with everybody on board because we've
also got operations going on underwater
so if something you know the sermon
happens during an operation in the water
then we have their work on the correct
reaction in a measured response for this
that's a rape coming in now
take care the equipment's coming in
around five boxes the guns and
ammunition we hope her never-used are
delivered to the ocean Zephyr in plenty
of time for the mission to piracy is
much reduced in the Indian Ocean
but the Aldabra atoll has been attacked
before far better to be prepared we've
got a few small boats off our port side
not really interested in us at the
moment sufficient
it won't be a concern and we see one of
the boats break off the culture waters
at speed but this is a trip about
science rather than security it is about
seeking evidence of what a change in
climate is doing to our underwater world
it all presents a challenge to
politicians that some are rising to but
many are not the United States will
withdraw from the Paris climate Accord
for instance America's withdrawal from
the Paris climate change Accord has
caused consternation among
environmentalists the Commonwealth
though is trying to do its bit with the
blue charter campaign how can we make
our response to the challenge that we
now understand with our ocean dying
potentially how do we make that
difference and so we created the Charter
which pulls together all the global
commitments that we have made as an
international community into one place
and basically says so now what are we
going to do about it Donald Trump makes
a habit of tweeting his skepticism about
manmade climate change and a strong
legally binding international agreement
to protect the oceans is proving
difficult to put in place but scientists
and many diplomats believe time is
running out we have to respond and we
have to respond now so our Commonwealth
family have no choice some of our
members are going to die if we don't do
the right thing now we are not
inhabitants of these pristine waters but
we are in many ways the custodians and
in that we may be failing it is why this
mission and the groundbreaking coverage
of it
we have emotions issues which goes like
this our children our treasures so if we
do not look after the resources and they
will have to enjoy when we are gone then
who are we how do we look at them in the
face or how do they see our memories our
children our treasures who knows what
treasure of life lies below it is the
goal of scientists to find out and the
mission to bring it all to you is about
to begin
[Music]